do not be fooled by our
politeness our bows our ma of
rituals death is in our
air and sea and
Earth just
remember we live and we
die we control nothing beyond
that
there's a saying out here every man has
three
hearts one in his mouth for the world to
know another in his chest just for his
friends and the secret
heart buried
[Music]
deep where no one can find
it
what kind of man wields power in a land
like
this the one in the open or the one you
never
see will I die here
likly war is coming
life and death are the
same both can have value and
purpose this is not why we die we should
be corpses I know but here we
are my life is mine and yours is
yours if you can't see that you'll never
be free of this
prison
it is you who is
imprisoned freedom is all you ever live
[Music]
[Applause]
for